[Music]
it's a fundamental assumption that all
mammalian species are the same but it's
really difficult to actually show that
that's true so this was sort of one of
my Holy Grail experiments was to look at
the biophysics of neurons how different
inputs are processed as they arrive into
neurons and integrated together and see
if that's different in rodents and in
humans the challenge is getting the
tissue from neurosurgeons and those
neurosurgeons have to be research
oriented they have to want to
collaborate and we did that with SID
cash over at MGH we obtained brain
tissue from patients with intractable
epilepsy who are undergoing neurosurgery
to remove abnormal regions deep within
the brain to do that we had to remove
overlying cortex that area of the brain
that's thought to be responsible for
higher order cognitive processing we
then took that piece of tissue placed it
into specialized artificial cerebral
spinal fluid and hand it off to mark
screw it's usually Lou and Derek
basically they are running down the
halls of MGH Hospital and out the door
and into a waiting car and then they
jump out of the door and then run it up
to the lab where we're waiting we take
it out put it into a new solution that's
oxygenated and cold and then we have to
take this out and orient it and figure
out how are we going to set it up on the
slicer physically so that we can get
these thin sheets of the circuit to then
go on the microscope that we can then
use to do experiments any misstep at
this stage basically ends the entire
case so I just put one of the brain
slices on our microscope over here and
under the microscope there's this sort
of moment in which we bring the brain
slice into focus and sometimes there's
just nothing there it's just it's just
dead but other times these are neuron
there there's another one here it's just
filled with live fat happy juicy looking
neurons so I'm gonna be here for 20
hours or something everyone's very
excited because it means you know two
days of data
so the technique that we used to record
the electrical activity from these
neurons is called patch clamping the key
principle is you take a piece of glass
tubing and you pull it into a little
tiny hollow needle and then you fill it
with an electrolyte solution so this
glass needle becomes an electrode and
then I'm gonna feed the pipette with
some dye and the glass has a really
fascinating property in that it adheres
very very tightly to the cell membrane
this is one of the challenges to doing
these experiments is you got to make one
of these pipettes you got to fill it
with the electrolyte solution you got to
put it on the rig you got to find a
neuron that you're interested in it
looks good it's healthy then you got to
get your electrode down in there you
know into the solution next to the
neuron it's kind of like playing in
there a science video game so now I'm
gonna put some positive pressure because
this is connected to the pipettes you
then push the pipette into the neuron
and then you release the pressure and
this little piece of membrane now I'll
get sucked up into the pipette
and then you can gain intracellular
access to the inside of that cell you
can also use it to fill the neuron with
dye so you can reveal the architecture
of those neurons and then you can
correlate the architecture the structure
with the function and so what Lou is
trying to do is have a recording
electrode near the soma but then another
electrode far away out in the antenna
structure the dendrites to see what
kinds of local processing operations are
taking place out there and then how that
dendrite communicates with the soma and
so we started to do experiments by just
looking at the dendrites that are the
closest to the soma in that space things
look very very similar so on one hand
that was a little bit disappointing we
were expecting you know specializations
that made us human but on the other hand
it's reassuring because okay rodents are
a really good model you know the past
you know 50 years of doing experiments
in rodents make sense they're an
excellent model system where we started
to see differences was when we looked
into the very faraway dendrites the ones
that are much much longer than
see the rodents and there we see that
their behavior is very different those
very distal dendrites are integrating a
bunch of inputs right independently of
what's happening at the soma so the
human neurons sort of form their own
individual kinds of neural networks it's
sort of a network inside a neuron so
that sort of conditional kinds of
interaction supports a very particular
mode of computation in the human model
so that's what we're starting to see
evidence for
Red Bull and coffee and no no no passion
passion for science course